this episode is sponsored by morningbrew
morningbrew is a free daily newsletter
that gets you up to speed on business
news in just
five minutes click the link in the
description to subscribe now
when it comes to moving ciliates are
spectacular to watch
they're hair-like cilia beat in waves
that steer them around the micro cosmos
and that's great if you're trying to get
from point a to point b but sometimes
you're not actually trying to get
anywhere you're just trying to be
slightly less in the spot you are
currently in
like these spirostomum which can grow
several millimeters in length that size
can be an advantage when they're looking
for food or
navigating the world around them but it
also makes them easy targets for
predators
same for the vorticella which anchor
themselves to substrates and then extend
their feeding heads
out into the microcosmos it makes them
kind of like fishermen waiting for food
to come by but it also makes them
sitting ducks for predators but
spirostomum
vorticella and many other ciliates do
have a way of defending themselves from
these attacks
contracting
contracting is like very very effective
flinching if you accidentally touch a
hot burner on the stove
you flinch and pull your hand away very
quickly
now imagine if you could not only pull
your hand back
but you could actually shrink your hand
down into your arm
to minimize the threat of the stove even
further
well the microcosmos does not have
stoves though i guess it could be said
that stoves
have a microcosmos but that's a story
for a different day
instead microbes are caught up in a
great game of marco polo with predators
responding to chemical and physical cues
to detect possible threats
and responding in their own ways of
course there's the tried and true
chemical defense which spirostimum
do use scientists have documented a
predator
vomiting up aspirostomum whose toxins
didn't digest
very well but while toxins are a good
defensive option
to have if you're a spirostomum or any
other ciliate
you probably don't want to get to the
point where you need to be vomited up
plus even if you've managed to evade the
same predator again and again
like spirostomum has there's plenty of
other obstacles to avoid the microcosmos
like poop i mean yeah when you have
video of spirostum getting pooped on you
have to use it
anyway whether you are avoiding
predators or their poop
contracting is a good response to have
and these contractions
are marvelous they are some of the
fastest things in nature and not only do
the contractions happen quickly
but the time between when the stimulus
is received and the contraction
begins is faster than any action
you have ever taken
scientists have been observing and
documenting different ciliates and their
contractile behaviors for decades now
and it's not hard to understand their
fascination
for one the contraction looks a bit
like the movement of our own muscles
just much
faster now it turns out it works much
differently
and it's also easy to get a cilia to
contract
and that turns out to be an important
thing when you want to study something
stenters have been a popular contractile
ciliate model because all you have to do
to get them from their distinctive
trumpet shape to a sphere
is pokemon with a glass needle now it's
important to note here
that we're using this word contraction
like it's a uniform
behavior done in the same way in all
ciliates
but just like how animals have a lot of
different ways to
run around ciliates have a lot of
different ways to contract
vorticella for example don't contract
their whole bodies
they spiralize their stalks which coil
them towards whatever they're attached
to and away from whatever stimuli has
set them off
and spirostomum have their own twist a
literal one
specialized membrane structures and the
long coil of microtubules
spin their ends while keeping their
middle stable
to activate a contraction in an
ultra-fast movement that was only really
deeply understood
in 2019 now again whatever the change is
for the organism though
one of the things that these species
share in common is that the contractions
are very
very fast so much so that it's taken
high-speed cinematography for scientists
to start to figure out how it works
stenters burrostimum and vorticella all
condensed to fractions of their original
length
in a matter of milliseconds a
contracting spirostomum can experience
forces of around
14g for comparison an elite fighter
pilot does not ever experience more than
nine g's of force and for vorticella the
rapid contraction of their stock
moves them at about 1200 body lengths
per second
that is very fast that's the equivalent
of a cheetah running a mile
in a second now interestingly while the
organisms we're highlighting today work
on the scale of milliseconds to contract
they are much slower on the recovery
taking more on the order of seconds
to extend back to their original state
now this makes sense
as the goal is to do whatever possible
to escape being eaten
so the initial quick movement is more
important than the
return to our normal activities movement
but the factors
driving this fast contraction and slow
relaxation
are both physical and chemical
physically
the bodies of these organisms contain a
mix of contractile fibers that work
together
and against each other to create these
movements
in stenters and spirostomum you can see
these special membrane structures
running along their bodies and in the
vorticella stock you can see
this helical contracting organelle
called the spasmoneme
whatever these things look like you can
think of any of these movements
not as sudden contractions of muscle
fibers but instead
as chemicals that change shape
in different chemical conditions if the
solution they are in
has a bunch of calcium ions the
structures are small and tightly coiled
if the solution has a low concentration
of calcium ions
they stretch out and so in all of these
cases
mechanical stimulation causes these
cells
to suddenly and rapidly allow calcium
ions
into the cell which causes all these
structures
to dramatically and rapidly change shape
but in order to return to the original
shape the calcium ions
have to be slowly and carefully pumped
out of the cytoplasm
so calcium ions are used across all of
biology
to carry information and cause changes
in all kinds of biological systems
including the biological system that is
you but this reliance on calcium ions
is kind of strange it's very common
but the evolution of these systems
relying on calcium is a little weird
because calcium ions can interfere with
reactions that are
key to our cellular metabolism
one recent theory to try and reconcile
this contradiction
is that the rapid calcium-driven
responses we are looking at right now
are part of a much longer evolutionary
arc
one built on the need for ancient cells
to repair
damage to their membranes in order to
prevent
a fatal influx of calcium ions from
their surroundings
the same urgency that could have driven
the evolution of this biological first
aid kit
might have then been rewired for other
rapid sensors and if this theory is
correct
it means that nature converted a defense
against a chemical
into a signaling mechanism that drives
everything from the contractions you are
watching
to the action potentials that are
helping you understand the words
that you are hearing right now
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
we would also like to thank morningbrew
again for sponsoring this episode of
journey to the micro cosmos
do you like to begin your mornings by
aimlessly scrolling social media
trying to find all the news that you may
have missed while you were sleeping and
never really sure whether you're getting
it and oftentimes finding stuff that you
don't actually need to be looking at but
looking at it anyway and then just not
feeling better afterward well
i know that i do with their daily
newsletter
morning brew is here to bring you witty
relevant
and informative business news all in one
place
and they make it easy for you to get up
to speed in just five minutes
the newsletter is written to be
accessible and include all of the need
to know information to get your day
started like
they recently had a newsletter feature
that condensed the key takeaways from
the iea's latest report on reaching net
zero emissions
by 2050 and the milestones that
governments will need to hit to make
that goal achievable
if you're interested in business finance
or tech there's no reason
not to subscribe to morning brew it's
completely free and it takes less than
15 seconds to subscribe
click the link in the description below
to subscribe to morningbrew
the people you're seeing on the screen
right now they are our patrons on
patreon they're the reason that we can
make this show so thank you
so much to all of them and normally
this is the part where we'd tell you to
check out our master of microscopes
james weiss's instagram jam and germs
but right now instead
we want to make sure that we tell you
that tomorrow as of the day this video
is going live
james's book the hidden beauty of the
microscopic world
will be out and available wherever books
are sold
we're so happy and excited for james
it's a beautiful thing
there's a link in the description and if
you want to see more from us
there is always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
you